[Music]  everyone's going completely insane these  days the same politicians and pundits  who got everything wrong before are  pretending that they have all the  answers now that's why we're asking the  hard questions on the Rubin report and  not going for the easy answer my guests  are liberals the burden is on you to  interact with these provocative ideas  conservatives I'm happy to treat you  with respect to have a civil discussion  I do it all the time and some defile  label we need to know how to identify  the radical leftists let's say and  separate them from the Liberals and  liberals are very bad at that  I'm trying yeah oh my god the beard has  a Twitter fanpage holy Christ  subscribe to the Reuben report and find  out why having old-school honest  conversation about politics philosophy  the meaning of life and much more might  be the only way that we're ever gonna  find some real answers  [Music]